and you know more than most people about
the feeling of fear like you're in a car
it's going really fast okay and there's
a party that says i'm going to die and
then there's a party who says i know i
can put the brakes on half a second
later or whatever it is you do i mean
i've been on a track but not like you so
you know there's that that edge you play
with oh yeah it's the name of the game
right well we all have that edge around
food
right and so oh my god i'm gonna die and
actually it takes me 90 days to starve
to death but you sure feel like you're
gonna die and you have more time before
you put the brakes on then then you feel
like you do and then you allow your body
and your reflexes
to tell you what to do right you get
this way with fasting but only after you
drop the fear and that's the whole
reason i wrote a book on fasting was was
that it's a psychological thing about oh
my god i'm gonna die i didn't have tacos
at noon you're not gonna die but man you
feel like you're gonna die
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense welcome to the pretty intense
podcast today on the show is dave asprey
he is the father of biohacking
he's a founder of bulletproof many of
you have probably heard of bulletproof
coffee founder
he's a four-time new york times
best-selling science author
he's also the host of bulletproof radio
podcast which i've been on and had so
much fun which led to him coming on my
show
so
man i mean there's just some episodes
that are just so dense in information
and this was one of them like it just at
every turn there's
things to try things to think about
things to go by
modalities to try but a lot of the
conversation revolved around metabolism
and the things that slow it down things
that speed it up we talked about sleep
we talked about crispr for those of you
who don't know what crispr is basically
genetic editing and so being a biohacker
i was just super
intrigued to see
what he thought about it and if he would
try it so much great information get a
pen and paper out because you're going
to want to probably write down a couple
things to try here's to upgraded health
such a pro dave oh thanks danica um
thanks for doing the show i had so much
fun talking to you a couple how long ago
was that a month ago or so or maybe
longer that was a fun conversation
all i remember is is there's the before
time and it's all kind of mushy so it
could have been a month could have been
three months but i remember two because
you're way fascinating you have all
these aspects to you that i totally
don't know about i mean there's always
what you see in in the public sphere
which is always inaccurate but yeah
you're you're smart oh
that's really nice of you i spent a lot
of my life using poor words about myself
and intelligence and saying that i'm not
very smart and kind of stupid i have a
ged and because i because i do i mean
like i don't there's a lot of
intelligence that i'm lacking when it
comes to
i don't know history like knowing
timelines and what year did the civil
war happen and things that you learn in
school because i again i i left for
racing when i was 16 so i didn't even
finish high school i got i got my ged
and so i dismissed intelligence a lot
but i i don't know if you've found this
but
um
with doing podcasts and interviewing
various different people i've
the older i've gotten i've had more of
an insatiable thirst for for knowledge
and
um learning about all kinds of different
things and so having fascinating guests
like yourself i i mean like i have a few
things that i want to talk to you about
that for me are are just cool things
they're so different and i'm not an
expert in them um but i totally want
your opinion and so i learn about that
or at least i scratch the surface on it
so i don't know if you feel the same but
i feel like intelligence is
growing at a much better rate than it
ever used to
you might be selling yourself short so
there's knowledge and there's
intelligence okay you're acquiring
knowledge rapidly but someone who
doesn't have intelligence can't make use
of knowledge
and you're really smart and now you're
filling up your your buckets full of
knowledge but you can use the knowledge
because you're a fast thinker and
because you have complex structures in
your mind right so your raw horsepower
where you might you know very well it's
actually really high if i was to just
kind of rate you given my experience of
you against the average human well
you're clearly going to be faster
because you have to have faster reflexes
but there's more than just being fast
like you're you're quick mentally and
you're able to assemble the knowledge so
the fact you didn't pick up some
knowledge in in high school you know
what most people get when they're 16 in
high school it's not knowledge they're
just learning social skills and dating
and you know trying to figure out how to
not get caught from their parents doing
stuff so you didn't miss that much
but
now you're like i'll just learn from the
experts and that's why i'm going to the
10th anniversary of bulletproof radio
now
and i started it going oh my god i get
to talk to the authors of the books that
i read anyway oh how cool is that and
that was my whole motivation so you're
totally on really have their what are
what are some of those first guests that
you got that you were like i can't
believe i'm talking too
well i mean i i got to interview deepak
chopra
which was like wow you know an in-person
interview there uh gary tobbs who wrote
good calories bad calories
um fascinating guy who's you know a real
journalist who's gone really deep
a nobel prize winner who discovered
neuroplasticity eric kandel
how do you get in front of a nobel prize
winner like there's a billion people
want to talk to them you're like oh i
have a podcast and like i'd be happy to
share so especially you because you have
such a big reach and you can call anyone
you want and pick their brain like what
a gift that is oh it's cool i know you
can do that now too i mean you can i
imagine that you know i had a different
head start because of a different career
but um but you and i could both probably
call most anybody and um and have a
conversation at least at some point in
time and that's such a cool thing that's
such a cool resource to have
um and i i just i'm fascinated i love it
um so
the first thing that i want to ask about
and it's because it just goes on in my
head and i know i have a feeling in my
body about certain things but i also
listen to the science i listen to people
like you
and it's it's a fundamental of course
it's about fasting and i just feel whole
i feel horrible like i i i'm starving in
the morning and i just i mean i was
probably
my leanest and healthiest i'd say in
general without any testing without any
kind of you know any kind of testing at
all but just visually and how i felt
when i ate like five times a day like
not overly eating at any point in time i
worked out you know one or two times a
day maybe once an hour maybe once 20
minutes but
that felt my best and i'm like man i i'm
totally
very curious about
how it really like what your thoughts
are especially when it comes to men and
women because oh yeah i just i'm just
i'm just up against that resistance of
the way i feel and i keep making the
excuse that it's because i'm a girl and
i think there's differences between them
so
something that i never used an excuse
for in the past is being a girl but now
i'm like it's because i'm a girl
it's it's really clear that women are
just little men i mean they're identical
i mean that assumption has been in
medicine until about oh 15 20 years ago
we started looking at differences even
in fasting studies
and
i do know we've had 70 000 people go
through my fasting challenge which is a
free thing you don't even have to buy
the book but it's fastthisway.com
which is by the way the name of my
fasting book and
i've had women from
22 all the way up to 82
say the same thing oh my god i just went
24 hours without eating and i didn't
notice it didn't bother me i thought i
couldn't do it so where you are danica
is totally normal you and i were both
told
if you don't eat five or six times a day
your body will go into starvation mode
and then you'll get fat right you heard
this before i bought that
totally and when i was at that 300 pound
level i was terrified in fact that's why
i had a shaman drop me off in a cave for
four days and i write about that in the
book
because i knew that i would be hangry
and hypogly [ __ ] and i would yell at
people i cared about and i was afraid of
being alone and i knew i would eat if i
was lonely and i went through
all of these things going all right i'm
gonna have to be like 10 miles away from
any other human to do it that was how
big my fear was
and i did fast for four days
but you don't have to fast for four days
you as a woman there are new studies
that look at women and men
12-hour fasts three times a week create
metabolic benefits like do that
you can do that because you sleep for
like eight hours i try okay
so if you have an eight-hour sleep that
means stop eating after dinner
okay have dinner at six four hours
before bedtime sleep sleep eight hours
right congratulations you're an
intermittent faster
and then you wake up you go you know
what i'm just gonna wait a little while
before i eat right what's that what's
that gonna be uh and that could be
suddenly it's a 14-hour fast but that's
all we're talking about because sleep
time counts as fasting time yeah and so
a lot of women are saying well i should
do an 18-hour fast every day right it
doesn't work and there's a chapter in
fast this way specific to the research
on women and what you'll find is
that if you look at the amount of stress
your body's under from all sources that
determines the length of your fast so if
you wake up and you're thinking god i
slept so well everything is perfect you
know i i'm just feeling really good and
i haven't lifted heavy i don't have some
high stress
race or event or something
i'm probably going to fast for longer
today because
fasting is a form of exercise or stress
for your body but if instead you say i
slept like garbage last night you know
maybe you had a hot flushes or
you know me come on dave
i mean i'm not that old yet no but
people listening are yeah you're right
you're 100 right
and that's a stressor and that's a
stressor
and you're super chill it's actually
really interesting
but
you
you go into all these things where okay
you people have fights they have a cold
right you something's not right well
okay how much is on that side of the
scale
and if you're saying well okay today i
was already kind of wrecked i think i'll
go fast for
24 hours and i'll lift heavy at the gym
and i'll get on an airplane and fly
somewhere
it's too much and so
women and men both
are capable of fasting and women will
hit the stress wall of fasting before
men do on average
and i love getting to talk with someone
who totally gets all the driving
analogies so the old expression of
hitting the wall we know where that
comes from right well
when you learn how to manage your
biology and how to fast
without being hungry
what it does is it moves the wall very
far away so i have more resilience and
power and energy than i ever did before
that gives you time to build up speed
so you still can hit the wall and i i
teach for women that the fasting wall
when you over fast is about four to six
weeks and what happened is the first
week oh my god i did it and then next
week
every day correct is this every day
every day it could be even five six days
a week but you keep making longer and
pretty soon you're going to say i'm only
doing dinner
and then with dinner oh that's too much
i'll just fast every weekend and
eventually you get to this point where
you know it worked but now you're not
feeling as good
since it used to work you're gonna do it
even more it called the fasting trap and
it works with a vegan diet it works with
the keto diet it works with anything
that works at the right amount you go
past the goldilocks zone sure first sign
bad sleep so the way you would know that
your fasting wasn't working is you wake
up in the morning you feel like you're
hungover but you didn't drink anything
the night before and the second sign is
monthly irregularity in your cycle
right that's weird it's normally
predictable and now it's not
well okay maybe you should actually eat
a little bit more or more often and the
third thing if you keep pushing yourself
and by the way
people who might i don't know drive race
cars or be professional athletes or be
hardcore entrepreneurs like the type a
people we are the ones who are going to
push harder right and then you say oh my
hair is getting thin
and it's funny so that's the four to six
week i'm fasting too much thing for
women
but then for men it's kind of similar
but it takes less usually six to eight
weeks
and for men it's
sleep quality goes away and then
i'm waking up without a kickstand that's
weird
and then the third thing is
my hair is thinning as well and and so
what we're doing here is we're saying
don't over train and as you know if you
exercise three hours a day every day you
start to not feel good it's the same
with fasting so that's the big thing for
women is it's okay
to not fast the same way every day and
shorter fast when you're already
having other stressors and longer fast
when you're not common sense
yeah
yeah
and you know more than most people about
the feeling of fear like you're in a car
it's going really fast okay and there's
a party that says i'm going to die and
then there's a party who says i know i
can put the brakes on half a second
later or whatever it is you do i mean
i've been on a track but not like you so
you know there's that that edge you play
with oh yeah it's the name of the game
right well we all have that edge around
food
right and so oh my god i'm gonna die and
it actually it takes me 90 days to
starve to death but you sure feel like
you're gonna die and you have more time
before you put the brakes on then then
you feel like you do and then you allow
your body and your reflexes
to tell you what to do right you get
this way with fasting but only after you
drop the fear and that's the whole
reason i wrote a book on fasting was was
that it's a psychological thing about oh
my god i'm gonna die i didn't have tacos
at noon you're not gonna die but man you
feel like you're gonna die and this was
what you had to overcome those four days
in the cave right or when oh yeah were
you in a cave were you in the wilderness
what were you taking anything was it
water was this a ayahuasca journey for
four days what was it i was literally by
myself in a cave with a sleeping bag a
fire a knife and a big big bottle of
water
i mean this is i resonated so much when
i heard that i i don't remember when i
heard that it was a while ago and i was
like that's how i feel like i might die
people know i'm a little food obsessed
at least i don't like throwing food away
i always have food on me i always have a
snack with me like it's always got to be
around because at that sort of i'd say
six hour mark during the day i'm like i
i might not even feel
hungry actually my mood shifts before i
feel hungry why is that
well you're getting hangry and what's
going on there is your body runs only on
glucose
and it's not metabolically flexible and
when you eat protein it can convert to
sugar in the body
and so
your body when you go for longer periods
of time without food or if you decide to
go on a keto diet for brief periods keto
is not good for men or women if you just
do it forever a lot of people keep
trying to do that that's bad
but you don't have to go keto you can
just do the intermittent fasting thing
and your ketones will rise and what
happens is the body goes you know what i
guess i should be pretty good at burning
fat and pretty good at burning sugar and
when the body burns fat your brains your
neurons are so happy because fat has
more calories than sugar so when you
burn that the neuron's like yeah we
wanted more power we have more power and
more focus
so you get that like i can't imagine
doing a mental high performance thing
without having some ketones present and
i i say that because i know how i feel
but i also know because i run a
neuroscience lab to teach people's
brains to become high performance it's
called 40 years of zen and people come
and spend five days with stuff glued to
their head and if i don't give them mct
oil which helps to make ketones that
feed those neurons they can't do the
high performance meditation learning
stuff that they're capable of
and so you're sitting there going okay i
want to be fast
then you want to teach your metabolism
you should be able to burn fat and you
should be able to kick over and burn
sugar as well and people only go keto
they can't burn sugar anymore and they
get insulin resistant so in your case
your body says
emergency could you eat because it's
learned to always expect sugar and when
you teach the body not you consciously
but the body to just be calm and go oh
there's no sugar here i'm not going to
die what i'm going to do is i'm going to
kick over my fat burning enzymes and i'm
going to start metabolizing fat and then
the calmness and the energy kicks on in
that moment in that switchover
is there discomfort is it only a mental
thing or is there an actual physio
physiological reaction happening that is
uncomfortable like you've heard of the
keto flu and things like that but is
that happening when you switch over like
should there be that little bit of grace
period where you go okay it's happening
when you're first learning how to do it
yes
once you've learned it's not
uncomfortable at all it's sort of like
the first time you were to go swimming
in a pool that's not really cold but
it's a little bit cool you jump in and
but if you do that every day you jump in
and go it's actually not that cold i'm
just going to jump in and it becomes a
non-event but when you first do it like
the water was only 72 degrees what am i
going to do and meanwhile you've got
michael's phelps swimming in 36 degree
water you know totally different area
i'm just saying mild discomfort
and
what i do in fastest ways i teach people
look
you have a job probably you're possibly
a parent and there's lots going on in
your life
fasting is a spiritual discipline when
you want to do a spiritual fast and
fasting is a high performance working
thing when you do it for performance
because when your body is busy chewing
up whatever foods in your gut it's not
using that energy to think or recover
it's actually using it to make more
energy so then you wake up in the
morning and say i don't want to feel
that discomfort nobody does and it's
okay you don't have to suffer too fast
so then there's three things you can do
in the morning that completely remove
the pain of fasting but allow your body
to still get the fasting benefits and
that's what you would start with
so that then you don't feel like you're
going to die the discomfort isn't there
and
you're sort of saying this was the best
morning i had because i never thought
about food and like everyone can fast if
you don't think about food right right
exactly so what are those three things
okay
um the lowest level one is just black
coffee
right and the reason black coffee works
and yes i did start a coffee company i'm
not running it anymore
bulletproof but the reason i'm talking
about black coffee is studies from uc
san diego show that just the amount of
caffeine in two small cups of coffee
doubles your production of ketones
when you're doing even a short
intermittent fast if you can get ketones
up a little bit ketones turn on a
hormone that makes you feel full and
they turn off the hunger hormone ghrelin
is the hunger hormone and cck is the
fullness hormone which is made by calvin
klein
not really
i'm kind of a nerd
so
when you do that okay black coffee
suddenly it was a lot easier and people
know coffee suppresses hunger but no
sugar and especially no artificial
sweeteners in the coffee because that
breaks your gut bacteria any of them
it's stevia you name it you should be
okay with stevia or monk fruit but
you're not gonna be okay with sucralose
and aspartame and all those chemical
ones those really are shown to cause
harm especially for weight loss
and then the second one is you can do a
bulletproof coffee which is grass-fed
butter and that mct oil blended in and
when you do that something happens to
the water that's in the coffee so that
your body can more easily use that water
even inside the brain
and it adds extra energy but because
it's got only fat your body says oh
there was no sugar there was no protein
all of the hormones of fasting stay low
so you actually got some energy
but all of your hunger is now turned off
you're like i just don't care about food
and i have tons of energy meanwhile your
body says i didn't have to digest
anything
you're still fasting and so all the
fasting benefits happen but you're
relaxed
and the third thing that you can add
either to water or to coffee or tea
whatever is prebiotic fiber and this is
fiber that does not raise your blood
sugar it has a very neutral flavor and
so there's no one on earth i've ever met
who can't put enough of this very
healthy fiber that feeds your good gut
bacteria in with some butter and some
mct and some coffee you blend it up and
you drink that you're thinking i am so
not interested in food right now but the
body says i didn't get any sugar i
didn't get any protein therefore i'm
going to be in fat burning mode and i'm
going to do the benefits of fasting
tomorrow morning if you do this danica
you will simply not care about food and
when lunchtime comes
you're going to say i guess i could eat
and it's going to be so liberating you
wouldn't even believe it prebiotic fiber
first off because i've seen a couple of
products and actually bought one the
other day because i'm doing all kinds of
testing all kinds of gut health rese all
kinds of all kinds of things going on
which is fascinating stuff and
um i've i've been diving in pretty deep
but it always has a carbohydrate is that
correct or at least the one that i found
and the ones that i've seen it always
seems like a prebiotic has
has as a carbohydrate base is that true
prebiotics are always made out of
carbohydrates
and that's okay though because we have
these
stories that became a part of our our
cultural
our cultural view like we have to get
our macros or how about this one
protein's good for you or better
plant-based protein is good for you
right right oh i've gone round and round
about all that too
didn't everybody try vegan for a minute
it made me really sick i did not enjoy
it either
but here's the funny thing my favorite
plant-based protein is sarin the nerve
gas that was used in the tokyo it comes
from beans
so
not all proteins are good for you and
not all plant proteins are good for you
by the way don't eat spider venom which
is an animal protein so
so wait like a good idea
maybe different proteins do different
things maybe different carbohydrates do
different things too got it got it and
right and the cool thing with prebiotic
fiber is that the body cannot digest it
even a little bit so from your body's
perspective it's invisible it doesn't
count as a carb it's just a filler
it was there's two sorts of fiber
there's
soluble fiber which is prebiotic and
then there's coarse fiber like sawdust
and your body will feel the sawdust to a
certain point because it provides like
space but when you eat the other the the
prebiotic fiber yeah it has no flavor
and the more of it you eat the longer
you're likely to live
your gut bacteria the good guys like yes
let's have a party and they start to
replicate and as they digest it they
convert it into a short chain fat called
butyric acid that is ketogenic and is
really good for your gut and really good
for your brain so now i'm so glad i
bought this the other day
yeah exactly so it's totally fine that
has carbs in it unless it has sugar or
unless it has digestible carbs and
this idea that prebiotics are super
filling is well
well supported by research and
this anti-aging effect by feeding your
good gut bacteria we would all live
longer if we had more than 20 grams of
soluble fiber a day and most of us don't
get that in our diet i take 60 grams a
day in other words in the morning i put
a couple scoops in my coffee and it
disappears and then i've had more fiber
than almost anyone else and
it tastes the same and then my body's
just not interested in food i remember
going down to mexico down to tulum and i
think i heard that they they believe
that there's two brains one in the
stomach and one in the brain like one up
here one down there the two brains and
one in the heart two one in the heart
yeah yeah where does collagen fit into
that because this morning what i did
actually because i was like you know
i'm gonna have so i put in some mct oil
i put in a little bit of it was a
vanilla ghee i don't know if it has to
be grass-fed butter but what i had was
vanilla ghee and regular so i use the
vanilla for fun
and i put some collagen in it so where
does that fit in to add collagen is that
not part of the protocol is that a
different kind of supplementation
i am probably the world's biggest fan of
collagen and the reason cauldron is a
big rage is that 10 years ago i started
really pushing this as we missed this
and it's become you know a commonplace
ingredient before that it was it was not
used for health
and if you are trying to lose more than
say 20 pounds or your metabolism is sort
of stuck and sluggish there's a case for
having protein in your coffee for a
month so when you wake up you have 20 or
ideally 40 grams of protein that'd be
four scoops of collagen
with right after you wake up and you do
that to reset your body's leptin
ingredient sensitivity but that's not
fasting that's telling your body hey
it's a circadian timing like like wake
up it's it's time for you to learn how
to metabolize protein in fat
when you're doing intermittent fasting
collagen or any other protein will break
the fast so what i recommend people do
if you wanted to have breakfast that
morning
don't have carbs for breakfast they just
make you hungry later have carbs for
dinner so you can sleep better so in the
morning a really good amazing breakfast
is you have some butter you have some
mct you can have coffee or tea whatever
you like and you can throw collagen in
there it's in your coffee mug you're out
the door
or you can drink it at your desk but
it's really satisfying and the collagen
of course hair skin
bones joints it's it's a necessary
protein that unless you drink bone broth
or something you just don't get in the
west
or you eat pig's ears like there's weird
stuff traditionally chicken feet and
pig's ears and all but i don't know
about you those aren't my normal diet
yeah let's not eat the pig's ears um so
where where does metabolism fit into
this because like right that's the old
story like if you don't eat your
metabolism slows down um but now we're
having conversations here about like
speeding up your metabolism by
um waking up certain hormones when you
get up so what actually slows it down i
was talking to my functional medicine
doctor the other day and she was saying
that sometimes
that she was saying that that
it's hard once you've had a reduction in
metabolism to get it all the way back
like if you've abused your metabolism
through
under eating too much calorie
restriction
things like that that it gets hard to
get it back and i don't want to believe
that you know i want to believe that you
know we could get anything back that we
wanted so what actually gets our
metabolism to drop and what what helps
bring it up
other than what you just mentioned about
what an awesome awesome question
and
i would support your doctor and that
it's harder to get it back but it's not
impossible it's not even that hard what
happens with most of us as we age our
metabolism flows down
or you do what i did go on a raw vegan
diet or get exposed to things like
toxic molds or excessive emotional or
physical stress you know uh
if you you could have a car accident for
instance you have whiplash and you're
just inflamed for a long time i don't
know what you mean feel good
right
and so then
all of a sudden something happens and
the body says more stress than i could
handle and then there's a central
thermostat in the body for energy
production and it's your thyroid
right now hashimoto's thyroid is just
rampant as a problem and it hits women
more than men and i have hashimoto's
i've had it since i was at least in my
early 20s
and when that happens i don't care how
much you love what you do i don't care
how
motivated you are your volume is turned
all the way down so you can yell but the
volume's down and until you get on
thyroid hormone with a doctor your
metabolism will not fix itself you can
fast all the time you can do cold
showers and they'll just make you feel
like crap you can go to the gym and
you'll just be tired so you've got to
fix the thyroid and anyone over 40
your thyroid is very likely to start
going down a little bit and you go to a
normal doctor not a functional doctor
and they'll say
oh you're within normal limits for your
age you say yes doctor but i'm tired and
i'm getting pudgy around the middle and
something's not right and say yeah but
your labs are okay a functional medicine
doctor is going to say oh you're at the
lower level of what's normal and you
have symptoms let's try it and you take
thyroid in the next day like oh my god i
love my life i love my family i love my
job i got my vibe back
and so that's one of the ways is just
thyroid thyroid thyroid and it's such a
big problem at all ages the first day i
had thyroid hormone i was about 26
and i just remember thinking i got my
brain back i i was so grateful like oh
this is how i'm supposed to feel and it
was the first day so you got to get that
tested if that's happening that's my
story for sure i mean before you go on
to the next one that's i mean like
that's kind of part of what has sent me
on the journey is like part of it was
cycle stuff and then it was like your
thyroid's low
and gaining weight for no reason and all
kinds of stuff and and so yeah i'm i i
it's very interesting all i can say is
it's very interesting i can't say i've
had that moment where i feel like i take
something and i'm like here i go oh my
god i feel better
do you know why why
it's because your normal level is really
fast
and i've just we've had enough time
talking like you can you can read
someone look
you live at a faster speed than most
people you just do so for you to feel it
it's going to be different the reason i
learned all the stuff that i know is
that i also normally my clock speed is
very fast but
given how sick i was as a raw vegan how
sick toxic mold made me i got to the
point where i was maybe at 10 of where i
am now so i could feel differences
because i was so wrecked so i took a
thyroid medicine for i've taken it for
this certain dose for
probably almost six weeks and
all of a sudden the tsh went um way down
and the t
4 was up but the t3 was still low so
because the t4 converts into t3 so the
message the tsh is the message from the
brain to the thyroid to convert it right
the way it works is
the body says i don't have enough
thyroid and then it sends out tsh which
says turn up the thermostat which is
like the shout for more thyroid then the
thyroid if it hears the tsh it says i'll
make some t4
and then the tissues convert the t4 into
t3 and what's likely happening with you
is it's converting into something called
reverse t3 that can't be used
so people get stuck at different parts
of the thyroid cycle and when you go to
a normal doctor they say oh your tsh is
fine and then you just feel like crap
all the time you go to a functional
medicine doctor and they figure out in
your case they're probably going to give
you straight t3 instead of t4 or they'll
give you a mix of t4 and t3 and when you
do that
that when you get t3 levels up which is
the one you feel you should say oh yeah
like i'm on today a little bit more than
normal
and that level's still low in me
okay once you get that out that's when
you're going to feel it because
ultimately if you don't have enough t3
that's the thing that really sets the
thermometer yeah
i told her i was like i don't feel any
different i don't feel any different i
don't think it's working she's like well
maybe her thought was that we overshot
the dose
so kind of bringing it back down because
the body's saying there's plenty of t4
we don't need to make any so there's no
t there's less t3 then so anyway science
experiment but you'll get there and you
get to the point you have enough t3 it
it's that's the thing that gives you
power the other thing that tends to
decline in women and men before we like
to admit it is testosterone if your
thyroid is just dialed in
right and then your testosterone is off
you'll have problems with stubborn
weight gain and for men and women very
different levels of testosterone but
it's part of what gives you your vibe
right so you have that zest for life
and if your thyroid's off you won't have
it and if your testosterone is too low
you won't have it
and i recommend
with a medical doctor you need to get
your levels tested you shouldn't just go
in and just take any hormone without
knowing where you are
but when you do that your desire to do
great things in your life and in the
world it just goes up right and of
course there's bedroom benefits for men
and women too for having adequate
testosterone because you want to go to
the bedroom but
it's more just like wow i've got this
it's a sense of resilience and power and
it's funny when those hormones are where
you want them to be
intermittent fasting becomes even more
powerful and if you're rested and you do
intermittent fasting you can
help your thyroid and you can help your
testosterone levels but
if they're already wobbly and you over
fast you'll actually suppress your
thyroid so i see people who over fast
and they make the thyroid problem worse
and i see people who never fast and
their metabolism problems get worse so
we're about finding the goldilocks zone
being kind to ourselves and learning
what it feels like when you fasted too
much and learning what it feels like if
you ate
three or five times a day for two weeks
in a row how do you feel when you wake
up and understanding
there's a great variance in there and
finding the level for you yeah the body
it's it's it's interesting and you know
i i sense that you're this kind of
person too there's a there's a tendency
to want to over achieve with something
oh of course the body says
um i don't think so we want to be
balanced and so it's such a great
analogy for everything in life the body
just tells you with these with the
results of testing that and with the way
you feel
that over achieving on anything
is
not going to make you feel better so
i i think that it's uh it's such a it's
such a good lesson in life that it's
about balance and the body is really a
good example of that it it's very much
about that and i i wish someone had
explained that to me in a way that i
could have heard when i was 19. right i
made six million dollars when i was 26.
i was a co-founder of a company that had
gone public and i lost it all when i was
28 which is a little bit of a stressor
[ __ ]
and
during that time though
as you know a high achiever you can burn
the candle at both ends but it's also
possible to burn it in the middle
because you can melt through the wax and
i was just doing that because that's
what you're supposed to do
and what's funny i created this this
field of biohacking the idea of changing
or taking control of your own biology by
changing your environment
and
i didn't understand any of that stress
stuff
and if i had i would have said hmm my
odds of getting autoimmunity just went
through the roof
and you look at how many women get
hashimoto's there's probably some
sensitivity to environmental hormones
that women have in environmental toxins
more so than men but part of it too is
that women have
now
a really large work burden and most
women still have a home burden that's
greater than men so the amount of stress
both emotional stress and just i have to
get all the stuff done and you want me
to feed the kids and whatever else and i
just worked a 10 hour day i think that
it adds up and that's one of the reasons
that women get more autoimmunity more
hashimoto's than men do
you know and it's not that either men or
women you have life easy all the time
but in the world of biohacking about 55
of biohackers are women and what i found
is that women on average are so much
better than men at knowing what's going
on below the neck so so guys will type a
burn themselves up by ignoring their
body
but
for some reason women seem to have a
better built-in sense of what's going on
in their body
that makes them it makes it easier for a
woman to learn how to fast it makes it
easier
to learn that oh this is what it feels
like when i'm doing too much or too
little and guys it's like we have to
sort of fall off a cliff before we
notice
yeah healthy these are some of the
questions about the fasting about that
is that and just about hormones and how
they work because men and women we are
different i mean biologically there's
some differences and
um
you know did you say that women are more
likely to have autoimmune diseases
they are especially hashimoto's yeah so
i thought it was fascinating i
interviewed jordan peterson and he said
that when a woman goes into
her fertile years and gets her cycle
that her anxiety
goes up and he
he
deduces that down to the fact that a
woman is meant to take care of a baby
and so
you are better served to be on
heightened alert
then
then not because you have to take care
of the baby and so i wonder how you know
the anxiety plays into
uh
plays into it because i do think the
mind is really powerful and we can talk
about that at some point in time i just
thought it was fascinating and he said
it never leaves either once the anxiety
kicks in like that doesn't really go
away i don't agree with him on that
there's some nuances there i wrote my
first book was on fertility and
pregnancy and how to have really kids
your first book as a guy that was what
it was about that's amazing it's called
the better baby book and it was my wife
was infertile she's a medical doctor and
we put together a program to restore her
fertility and to this day she takes
about a dozen clients a year and helps
them get pregnant people you know around
the globe
and it's uh
fertility like that the anxiety it
changes when you have a baby there is a
real thing called mommy brain where your
ability to focus changes your
sensitivity to sound your anxiety goes
up but the anxiety before that
isn't because you're supposed to be
taking care of a baby in your your
fertile ears
the anxiety especially around food comes
from the fact that if you're in a world
without enough resources and that means
either not enough of the right nutrients
you know like grass-fed meat and egg
yolks and the fat that is the substrate
for your hormones in your brain and
making a baby and without enough protein
in other words if you're a vegan um or
sorry i was a vegan too um or if you
um are then exposed to huge amounts of
environmental stress including just over
exercising what that means to the cells
in your body in your ovaries oh there's
a tiger chasing you every day oh and
there's a famine at the same time now
if as a man i was to get a woman
pregnant in an environment like that i'm
not gonna die
but as a woman if you get pregnant in an
environment with too much hunting of you
and not enough food for you it is a life
and death thing for your body for the
species and for the reproduction of the
species and of course it makes sense
that there'd be more anxiety about that
but that isn't just because you have to
be taking care of babies once you're
fertile that's because if you had to
take care of a baby when you're fertile
and you didn't have the right
environment for it
your body knows it's life and death and
you feel that
right so there's a nuance there but once
you have kids though the brain shifts in
some women it shifts much more than
others
right and this is something that lana my
wife uh has thought about writing a book
about because some women you know ceo
moms
they have a baby and like i can't do the
ceo job i it doesn't work anymore and
other moms pop right back and it has to
do with hormone levels and it's so
fascinating so hormones are so real i
mean that's all i'm going to say the
hormones are so real i did ivf back when
i was 33 to freeze my eggs and
afterwards i gained some weight and i
was like i always kind of thought they
were like ah it's my hormones i'm
getting older and i'm like i have this
sort of like
little gritty attitude where i'm like
just try harder and then it happened to
me and i was like
oh [ __ ] hormones are real
it's so not about trying harder anytime
someone tells a fat person to try harder
it's like no like you you might be heavy
because you have an emotional issue
around food a lot of people do i
certainly that was part of what's going
on with me but you probably have a
biological issue right and it you can
fix your metabolism you can get rid of
the toxins you can fix your gut but it's
complex and it's not it's your fault in
that you can fix it but it's not
something you did on purpose and god
knows it's not being lazy because people
with extra weight have less energy
because our energy goes into fat instead
of our brains and fixing ourselves so
the heavier you are the more of a
willpower athlete you are because you're
using willpower all day long it's just
not working because you're doing the
wrong stuff
okay let's get back to metabolism i know
i interrupted and kind of took us off on
a tangent i should have let you finish
but um so we were talking about the
things that reduce it and you were
talking about thyroid we're talking
about testosterone being a part of that
um what are there any other sort of
really mainstream things that would slow
it down a lot of people get heavy metal
toxicity yeah only two one a ton like
mercury off the charts mercury and lead
mercury lead there's like there's one
with a b and one with the t
thallium yeah thallium's high and burat
beryllium beryllium is high yeah like
i'm doing a gut rehab but she's like
after that we're doing the detox the
metal detox so i had very high mercury
and lead levels um even in my my 20s
and
i i was actually kind of a gray color a
lot of the time and you're trying to
lose weight these things suppress
your mitochondria the things that make
energy in your cells the things that are
responsible for all the stuff you do
so the first time i got a treatment for
heavy metals it was a chelation where
they would put something in
intravenously and came home and my wife
was like oh your skin's pink that's
interesting
because i had better oxygenation because
of this so
if your metabolism isn't working right
and you actually have something that
slows your metabolism
well there you go that could do it
mercury is a huge problem because we've
burnt so much coil that so much coal not
coil
that it's
it's in the oceans and it's in our
environment
and mercury is a pernicious toxin if you
have metal fillings you're getting a
regular dose of mercury and for years
the dentistry association fought to keep
those as oh no that's totally fine yes
they're toxic waste once we pull them
out and we have to dispose of them with
the epa but when they're in your mouth
it's just fine and that thankfully is
almost done dennis recognized it was
making them sick and it was making their
patients sick but if you're over
probably 35 there's a good chance you
could have mercury fillings and if you
go to a normal dentist and they drill
them out it'll release a huge wave of
mercury in your body you go to a special
mercury dentist and they'll know how to
safely remove the toxin from your mouth
but it may be the fish you're eating
right and it can be other things so you
get your levels tested and you can do
with a urine test yeah that's what i did
it's really easy
it's super easy and then you go oh wow i
have this going on now what am i going
to do about it and there's a variety of
binding things for different ones but
thallium let's talk about that one
because it's interesting
thalium is known as the poisoner's
poison
and the russians used it to kill people
before they came out with like polonium
and all the cool new radioactive stuff
they like to use
by the way i'm totally i have no actual
fact that they don't this is what you
hear in the media sure that's okay let's
go with it what uh uh what thallium
does is it displaces potassium in your
cells and potassium is a very important
mineral we all know you need enough
potassium so people who get falling they
don't know why everything is slow they
don't know why they don't feel good and
just over the course of a few days after
a big dose of thallium you just kind of
slowly die and no one can really figure
out what it is unless they're a really
advanced toxicologist that's why it was
really good you give it to someone
disappear and then they die four days
later wasn't me
so
how are we getting thallium
the number one cause is you know lead's
bad for you you probably have high lead
like i did as well okay well lead was in
gasoline and pain so we took it out of
gasoline guess what we replaced it with
in gasoline
thallium
valium is a thousand times more toxic
than lead and lead any gasoline
it's yeah the unleaded gasoline has
valium in it so we burn that and it's
all around the environment
oh and oh it's not just breathing it
breathing it's a problem i'm guessing
they have unleaded gasoline and race
cars so you probably got some there but
you don't have to worry about breathing
it you don't breathe that much gas the
petroleum would mess with your brain
long before the thallium would
it's that
kale
is the number one chelator of
thallium from our soil so kale absorbs
thallium better than any other plant and
when i was a raw vegan what did i do i
pounded the kale which also causes
kidney stones and joint pain and oxalic
acid and all this other stuff but yeah
you're getting heavy metal poisoning
when you're having kale all the
cruciferous veggies do it a little bit
but kale is off the charts yeah and so
blah were you a kale fan by any chance i
mean i did used to eat a lot of kale and
then you said do you know how what it
was that video where you posted with a
stomach and you're like how do i know
what is the how do you know if you've
had kale without saying you've had kale
and you're like yeah and your belly's
sticking out and i was like it's kind of
like when sideways says i'm not gonna
drink any [ __ ] merlot i was like not
drinking any merlot when you said that
i'm like i'm not gonna eat any more kale
anymore
but i used to eat a lot of kale and my
functional medicine doctor said the same
thing she's like you can clean soil
of
uh thallium with uh and and other metals
maybe but she said you can clean soil
with kale you just gotta throw it away
when once you've grown it get rid of the
kale and if the kale is if this the soil
is really clean
and you love kale and you have some kale
once a week i don't care but if you do
what i used to a kale salad every day
it it is provably not good for you
and so i had fun making that that was
like my first real humorous instagram
video because i i do good job well it
totally worked well thank you
i like to pick on kale just because it
it was such a thing and actually i don't
like it and it's just oh and it's also
bad for your thyroid kale is so there's
that
um so so there's the metals and if your
metabolism is not working that's
interesting and then you say what about
our gut bacteria we mentioned prebiotic
fiber
there's really interesting studies that
show
if you take gut bacteria from a heavy
person and put them in a thin person
they'll get heavy and you can take thin
person gut bacteria put them in a heavy
person
and they lose weight
so
it's
you look at that go maybe it's not my
fault maybe it's not that i didn't
exercise enough or that i ate too many
leaves of lettuce or something it's that
there's
uh something wrong in the system
and
what i find interesting is these two big
species of gut bacteria one's called
bacteriodes and one called spermacutes
and there's a
kind of a balance between the two but
thin people have more more bacteria
deities and less from acuities and
they're both good for you but it's just
it's about a scale like which which way
do you balance the scale
and
one of the reasons i believe people have
lost more than a million pounds on the
bulletproof diet is that when in the
morning you do that thing with
mct and butter and coffee
well
any oil when you eat it suppresses gut
bacteria like it's antimicrobial in
general particularly mct
so that means you just kind of whacked
all of your gut bacteria on on the head
but then
the good guys the
bacterio deities you can't take them as
probiotics all you can do is feed them
and make them grow they like to eat
polyphenols which is the colored
compound in coffee coffee's the number
one source of polyphenols in our diet so
what you're doing it's like you mow the
lawn and then you fertilize the good
guys after you just punch the bad guys
and then you do that over time i think
it's one of the reasons that that that
made such an effect on me so there's an
immediate energetic thing hunger
suppression but there's got to be a
shift in the gut bacteria because we
only learned in the last like five or so
years how important the colored
compounds from plants are to shift your
gut bacteria doesn't mean you should eat
kale right because you're getting all
the toxins with the plant but you can
take safe forms of plant compounds that
signal your body to do good stuff
wow that's fascinating you can't add it
you can only feed because when you think
about bacteria and you think about
probiotics or prebiotics or any of those
kinds of things you think i can just add
it but you can't you need to can you add
some or is that and add some it's sort
of like if you were to go to the the
store and you were to buy some really
good seeds to plant some kind of a
garden thing and you just toss them in
the backyard
it's not gonna work right but if instead
you prepared really good soil with lots
of nutrients and then you planted the
seeds they're going to grow
so for your probiotics to work you have
to take prebiotics and prebiotics are
sometimes soluble fiber
and sometimes colored compounds from
plants
but if you take a colored compound with
a plant that also comes with a bunch of
stuff that causes inflammation
throughout your body like i don't know
bell peppers do that for a lot of people
who don't know it
then okay who cares about the colored
compounds because you got more downside
than benefit so what i tend to do is i
get my polyphenols from
blueberries from
chocolate from
coffee from tea
and from herbs and spices because
they're very concentrated right and then
i eat the veggies that don't cause
inflammation and i've spent a lot of
time there's a
daveasprey.com
probably slash roadmap
that's kind of the condensed diet on one
page you print out it says hey these
veggies cause inflammation for a lot of
people and you didn't know it because
not all plants are good for you in fact
about 95 of plants on the surface of the
planet will kill you if you eat them
like they'll make you really sick
right like go in the forest and eat some
leaves and you'll be like oh my god what
happened to my gut
so is it possible that some plants are
more edible than others and that was
what i discovered was some of my
pain in my joints some of my
inflammation even some of my weight gain
was from foods that i thought were
healthy that were well it's better than
starving to death but it's not healthy
and people take that polyphenol things
they eat a variety of rainbow colors to
be healthy that's garbage advice
you need the colored cumin i bought that
one too come on i bought that one too
eat the rainbow don't eat the rainbow
do you know what happens if you eat a
big bucket of rainbow colored beets
i don't
you poop those colors you poop those
colors
actually you do if you're eating the red
beets but what happens is beets are very
high in oxalic acid and they're very
high in something that makes nitric
oxide which people say oh that's good
that's what viagra does nitric oxide is
good for you what they don't tell you is
that oxalic acid causes kidney problems
and inflammation and swelling and food
cravings in a lot of people so beets may
do that and then if you get the nitric
oxide depending on your genetics it may
be the really bad inflammatory nitric
oxide or it may be the kind that gives
you erections you just don't know but if
if when i was a raw vegan i'm like oh
give me more beets i'm gonna be good i'm
like i wonder where my joints hurt all
the time and i'm cold and well yeah okay
there you go
all right so what can we do to speed up
the metabolism then so those things are
a couple of things that you know slow it
down what can we do to help it another
one that works for just about everyone
is getting enough iodine we put iodine
in sea salt or not in sea salt and
regular table salt but we also put
aluminum and some other stuff that makes
it not so good so most health conscious
people have switched to either sea salt
or mined salt from himalayas or from
utah
various types like that pink himalayan
sea salts okay yeah the pink himalayan's
the most common right for health people
but it doesn't have iodine in it and so
unless you're eating some oysters and
stuff like that or liver you don't get
much iodine and iodine
in large part helps the thyroid do its
job right so if you were to increase
your intake of iodine it makes a
difference and especially if you're in
your fertile years as a man or a woman
but specifically women there's probably
about a five-point global iq reduction
from lack of iodine
in our
in our nutrition so if women this is a
global thing it's probably less of an
issue in the u.s because of iodized salt
but if you look around just having
enough iodine increases iq in kids
especially babies so how do you take
iodine you can get iodine that you
literally put on your arm and you rub it
in it goes in through the skin and it's
called lugol's iodine you can get iodine
capsules they're usually low but this is
a cheap supplement that you can do if
you use the stuff on your skin 25 is
probably enough to last you for three or
four years like it's you know you get a
little bottle put on a few drops every
now and then and be done with it
the
other things that are really important
for getting your metabolism working at
this point we know vitamin d is just
critical you got to do that
uh
yeah i was too and now i keep my levels
between 70 and 90. and that is
that is one of the things where you
could say how much should you take to do
that without a test you will not know
because your genetics can mean you need
three times more than the person next to
you to get the same results oh wow a 15
000 i use a day for me
the standard u.s recommended amount is
400 i use which is criminally low
um but it's huge for immunity too i mean
this is like immunity is low when you
have low vitamin d and obviously this is
such a hot topic but um yeah vitamin d
lots of good purposes for that i i'm
really happy that the 8 trillion we
spent on protecting ourselves from the
pandemic did not go to sending vitamin d
to everyone in the country because i
mean who knows what we might do if we
had active immune systems that could be
terrifying just terrifying
yeah yeah
yeah god we could have we could talk for
hours about that but exactly
the
so i'm thinking about this your vitamin
d the other thing that most people don't
recognize
is that if you want your metabolism to
work right you've got to know how to
sleep
and
the first ingredient for high quality
sleep and for telling your body what
time of day it is because what you want
is you want your brain and all of your
tissues to know that it's sleepy time
and if you do something that scrambles
that system part of your brain or your
body thinks it's wake time and part of
you thinks of sleep time and then you
get bad sleep
so to make your metabolism work well you
need to have it lined up and the number
one sign for your body is light
and there's a chapter in fast this way
about how to combine light and food
timing in order to become a morning
person if you want to be and i never was
in my entire life but i am now because i
learned how to do this and also how to
deal with jet lag and what the second
signal for timing is is food
and if you imagine go back two billion
years
we're basically ancient bacteria
floating in the ocean
and the sun comes right overhead we're
getting all the spectrum of light and
it's coming in right here and it's all
warm and that's when there's the most
algae because they're growing and then
we eat all the algae and we're hey you
know our bacteria stomachs are full and
they're throwing eyes yay exactly right
and then the sun starts to go down it
shifts into that sunset color and it
gets cooler and then we go to sleep
right and then the sun comes up well
your body is still tied to that so if
you want to really rock your day
wake up in the morning and open the
curtains
take off your glasses or contacts so you
get full spectrum morning light in your
contacts too
contacts too contacts are blocking the
ultraviolet that's part of the signal
so don't put the glasses on because i
take i wear contacts but i wear glasses
at night so even in the morning like
take the glasses off too and yeah
blurrily gaze into the light
you don't even have to stare at the sun
but just 10 minutes outside do some yoga
poses or something
they say 20 minutes but honestly 10
minutes work and that tells your body oh
look the angle and color of the light
this is morning time and it's called the
scn part of the brain and then
when should you eat well in the middle
of the day so if you wanted to reset
your timing you eat between 12 and two
and that's your primary meal of the day
and you don't have to do this forever
most of the time we eat dinner as our
primary meal and do that and then have
an earlier dinner
and then at bedtime you turn off the
lights at night you make it dim
and what i do in fact i'll turn this on
behind me
let's see if i can make it red back
there
and i'm going to turn these guys off my
camera might not pick it up there's a
red i can see the right is it a
border there's a red light behind me
that it's kind of it's not turning i see
it it's behind your head right behind
your head yeah it's behind my head yeah
so the reason i do that is that
at night red light doesn't mess with you
and we've all heard about blue blockers
it turns out there's three other colors
of light that mess with you and one of
the companies i've i've started is
called true dark and we make glasses
that block all of the stuff that messes
with your sleep
and then a lot of people are saying okay
i'm going to be healthy i'm going to get
blue blockers and wear them during the
day because fluorescent lights aren't my
eyes or led lights if you block out blue
light during the day blue light tells
your body to wake up so then you never
wake up all the way so blue blockers
during the day are bad for you you can
block some but not all and at night you
need more than blue and for me
that has been a big a big
way that i make things work so i am 6'4
i'm about 230 pounds and somewhere
around 12 body fat right now
which is
okay i'm 48 pretty fit
pretty fit
and i don't work out all the time so to
come from being a 300 pound obese
pre-diabetic
person in my 20s to be able to do this
without spending a lot of time on it
sleep is a part of it and doing that
thing with the true dark glasses where i
carefully make sure i sleep well that
speeds up your metabolism
one night of bad sleep lowers your
ability to regulate blood sugar by 40
this is why i'm so religious my kids
like dad you're putting your glasses on
at night you know and now though they'll
put them on if we're traveling because
they found out oh we can sleep if we
wear the glasses otherwise you know
airport lighting and hotels mess with us
and it's it's become a really big thing
what do you think about wearables i feel
like there's so many people
that wear them i mean i have it i have
it i'm training for a marathon so i've
gotta watch and doing things with it
that are not necessarily
about sleep but it has that feature and
honestly i don't like it i sleep i i
mean i'm a weird sleeper meaning
i don't
wake up tired ever like almost ever see
you
you're
you're a little bit of a superhuman
okay the number of people who hear you
say that are like i hate danica
seriously most of your listeners wake up
feeling tired and the few of them who've
never woken up feeling tired like you
are like i don't know what you're
talking about it's not in my universe
because your universe is different
because you're like look i i'm hyper for
my wake up i'm full of energy and you
actually like you like vibe with that
energy uh when you you go somewhere when
you show up with that energy when you're
on the track you show up the energy when
you're on camera and and you can see it
right like like you've got like a like a
little happy
kind of playful but it's powerful right
and
and you can turn it on
but
most people when they wake up in the
morning they don't know how to turn it
on and i didn't right and now i know how
to turn it on but it for me i had to fix
my sleep architecture and if you when
you look at your sleep monitor so i have
an aura ring um it's o-u-r-a as the
company i've heard those are the best
those i mean that's what has the best
reputation they they are and i i'm an
advisor and investor in the company so i
would i would say that anyway but uh i
wouldn't lie if it wasn't true i
validated this with dan gartenberg a
sleep scientist from the university of
wisconsin who's gone through with a
million dollar grant and studied this
compared to other things and i really
feel confident that it's the best but is
your watch good enough sure
and
what i recommend people do is track what
you hack if you wake up feeling great
all the time
there's one or two things going on you
could have no awareness i think i'm
feeling great but there's 10 levels
above that that you've never accessed
but i don't think that's true for you
right because you wouldn't show up in
your life the way you do if that was the
case so then you don't need to fix your
sleep so don't bother tracking it and go
track something that matters to you
because if you track everything you just
fall in this this pit of oh my god maybe
i didn't do it right am i perfect enough
and it creates anxiety you can just toss
all that track what you hack that's what
i worry about is that with people they
let this be their dictator on whether or
not they have a good day or don't have a
good day in their mind because they're
like oh man i only got
five minutes of rem sleep tonight and i
thought i feel great like i thought i
had a great night's sleep and i just
think that that can be a little bit so
at least we're the best of the wearables
if you're gonna do it um
but but sleep very important i've always
been very perplexed by my sleep and i'm
i know i can be sound like a dick when i
say i don't really need sleep i truly
could i mean i want eight hours i try so
i wish i could get eight hours but
truly my number is more like six and a
half to seven
and that's like me doing great um but i
could pretty well function on
five
okay we're wired the same way um there's
some genetic stuff that there but i'm
going to set you free of that concern
the largest study ever done of sleep was
1.2 million people tracked over three
years
and that is an enormous amount of data
and it's the only one that had enough
granularity to look at the differences
between six and a half versus seven
versus seven and a half versus eight
guess how long the people who live the
longest sleep
eight i would think that's what you
think right they sleep six and a half
hours a night they don't sleep eight
hours a night so you're actually
sleeping the amount of time that a
healthy person sleeps it's not because
less sleep makes you live longer is
because healthy people need less sleep
so if you're getting enough of the right
nutrients you're living in an
environment that's supportive of your
biology
you
it's okay to feel rested and get six and
a half hours of sleep there is really
good data to support that if you sleep
eight hours a night you die more from
all cause than people who sleep six and
a half hours on average and if you need
nine hours of sleep you should really be
careful because the risks of sleeping
nine hours a night of needing to do that
are greater than the risks of sleeping
five and a half hours a night wow
okay so don't push yourself to get eight
hours i don't i don't get eight hours on
weekends i don't need it like i i've
gotten five times this year i've had
more than eight hours of sleep
right and that's okay i sleep six six
and a half hours i'm totally good to go
you've changed my life now in two
different ways one you just told me my
sleep is somewhat ideal
and then the other thing that you told
me when you interviewed me was that i
could eat duck eggs instead of chicken
eggs and i should be fine and
literally like changed my life i mean i
don't i'm running low i only have eight
left right now and i'm like where am i
gonna find a farmer's market but um
but uh but that changed my life so i i
have to say thank you um very much for
that you're so welcome so there's one
other thing i want to talk to you about
and it's it like gets into ethics and
i'm just kind of curious of your
thoughts about it but
i
i my brain has i watched something about
this a few years ago it wasn't the
greatest of docs
then i watched another doc about this
the other day and i thought that's
amazing and i didn't even realize it but
before i watched that about two weeks
ago i bought a book
called codebreaker
and i have i in my mind i'm so curious
about crispr
and i'm kind of curious from your
perspective
what being being a hacker being someone
who's trying to idealize things and
optimize your body
how you know what your thoughts about
crispr art maybe it's
or do you check in do you know about
crispr much
oh yeah okay so maybe explain to people
what it is because again i'm i'm really
scratching the surface with it but i'm
very curious and then i'm just kind of
curious to hear your thoughts what you
think you know where what what's coming
down the pipeline and if you'd be
willing to do whatever
crispr is a relatively new technology
that lets you edit a specific
gene and take a very small part of it
before we had sort of very primitive
ways of trying to change genetics around
so we can now with precision pull out
just a little bit of this and put a
little bit of something else in
and of course biohackers like me are
saying
wow
maybe we can fix genetic weaknesses that
we have
right and i believe that it's a hundred
percent ethical for us to have full
control of our own biology so if i want
to get giant hoops in my ears i want to
get weird piercings or
heck if i want to remove my left arm for
cosmetic reasons it's my right to do
that it's just dumb okay but it's my
right to be dumb because it's my body
and my body my choice right
so
um
that said i think there are great risks
that some countries are and i actually
interviewed someone about this on my
show a while ago
who couldn't talk about some of it
because of his government connections
but
um
there are countries probably including
the us but certainly some other
countries who are doing that science
fiction were going to use crispr to edit
humans and make super soldiers from the
embryo if you are going to reproduce
right now i don't believe it's ethical
to use crispr to edit your own genome in
a way that could be passed down into our
germline because we just don't know
enough but if you wanted to do
what i'm planning to do
using liz parrish's work and she's been
on my show is you can go in and you can
change things things like mtor the
ability to put on muscle you can fix
metabolic problems in my case i'm
relatively sensitive to environmental
toxins like toxic mold because of
something called hla dr4 can i edit
those with crispr not yet but will i and
and would i yes
and in fact i'm talking about that at
the biohacking conference
september 17th in orlando
i've been putting this conference on
every year and i invite people who are
doing potential gene editing for humans
right now is to treat diseases but dying
of old age is a disease and i want to
treat aging with crispr so i think it's
going to happen but for i don't think we
have a right to do it in a way that
makes us pass it down to our offspring i
do know one very wealthy person who did
go through
and
i don't believe he used crispr he used
another technique but basically removed
cystic fibrosis from his germline
and he did that this is a very wealthy
individual
because most people couldn't do that and
also there's secrecy and stuff
but overall i am
i'm not concerned
about
someone doing something stupid to
themselves because we do crazy things
you know what we do sometimes we get in
cars when we drive really really fast
where he might hit a wall
that's okay but it's not okay to like
get healthier with something i mean it's
just such a fascinating thing i i you
know watching this show about you know
you know and just thinking about the
potential of
you know ridding
you know society of childhood diseases
and things that would
you know hold them back in life and not
allow them to experience the the
fullness that's possible um
you know and i i mean there's some stuff
you can see man that's kind of
interesting
what a gift and then my mind goes yeah
there's the ethics side of it where
we're messing with human nature but from
a spiritual perspective if our
consciousness is not really our body
then
in the conscious and consciousness is in
the collective this is exit this exists
now
is this not just part of the path is
this
i mean we're just is this just how
human evolution is going
well you've got to remember epigenetics
often times but not always trump's
genetics and what epigenetics is
is that there's
an entire set of things that can be
turned on and off in your genetics based
on the environment so you put someone
with bad genetics in a good environment
well depending on the genes they'll do
better off but sometimes you can't turn
on a gene that's not there and we might
be able to add that gene
and
that means though our environment is
messing with human nature a lot and
we're spraying glyphosate on our soil
which is sterilizing the soil of
bacteria that our bodies need okay we've
messed with human nature
you and i are sitting here underneath
artificial lighting with air
conditioning we mess with human nature
we process food so we're already doing
it in a thousand ways
and can we consciously do it and then
how do we make it so that you get to
pick with full transparency
what happens with the modifications you
choose versus someone else getting to
pick and force it on you
and there's some very dark science
fiction places you can go where oh
everyone has to get a brain implant when
they're born and i mean we've all seen
altered carbon fantastic tv show i don't
know that i want to live in that world
right so the transhumanism part of this
some of it's uplifting and empowering
and some of it is really scary i come as
a computer hacker this is my background
in silicon valley so i know what bad
things big companies and governments do
when you give them technology that lets
them do things they ought not to do to
people and i'm concerned about having
any tech in my body that i don't have
full control of
uh and i in fact i'm concerned about
other immune systems and also i'm
probably the last guy to get an implant
that you know like a brain implant but
i'm probably the first guy to put a
helmet on that would read my brain waves
and tell me how to do it better
right and when it gets to the genetic
side if i was working with a geneticist
and it was custom for me and it was
going to cut my cancer risk by 90
percent and remove
pre-diabetes and remove diabetes
and it was going to remove alzheimer's
disease
i'm pretty darn sure that i want that
custom thing 3d printed and injected
into me because it's going to improve my
quality of life my energy my abilities
show up in the world
but it better not have a sneaky side
thing with malware in it that's what i'm
concerned about
right
right
full disclosure is the question right
yeah
it is indeed and there's a lot of people
who are scared of new technology like
that and
you shouldn't be scared of it you should
be curious and cautious
right and it doesn't mean you have to
jump and be the first one to do any of
these things be victorious you just got
to be vicarious right
i was gonna say it but you said it there
you go
and we did this without saying anything
we weren't supposed to say i think
that's a sign of maturity is when you
can hear all sides when you can draw
your own conclusion when there's no
animosity there's no
um you don't get wound up there's no
there's no no yelling and screaming
there's no putting your hand up or
putting the wall up it's it's a matter
of just fluidly kind of
hearing it all i mean that's how i mean
i think that you know that's
that's that's that's the ideal position
to be in but that's not exactly how it
all goes and so
um i appreciate your vicariousness
thank you
your question about crispr is is an
example of that some people immediately
say you can't but look we've done all
sorts of stuff including fly and that
people said that if if we ever flew that
it would be the end of us they said if
we drove more than 16 miles an hour all
the oxygen would leave the car and we
would asphyxiate this was truly people
believe this okay and then someone does
it like oh and like i'll raise man i'm
planning to be the first person to live
to at least 180.
right maybe maybe i won't but i'm like
let's race right actually i shouldn't
say that to you
well i mean i feel confident i'd beat
you in the actual race on in a car but
the other one who knows yeah i'm curious
i'm curious to see the evolution of how
that goes is there anything um in the
pipeline that you're you're testing and
working on and and and and
loving i think we have a right to
recover way faster than mother nature's
wants us to
and my company upgrade labs and we've
been in at the beverly hilton we're in
santa monica we just opened in victoria
but
we last week started doing franchising
so i've i'm creating at least a hundred
of these in the plan over the next 18
months i need one in scottsdale if
that's possible almost certainly
scottsdale i can't imagine someone won't
want that franchise right and what's
going to happen there is
you can go in and you can use the
technology that astronauts use and all
sorts of sports professionals to recover
really fast it takes way less time than
going to a gym you can get muscle or you
can get cardio in in vanishingly small
amounts of time and then you can spend
the rest of the time making the brain
work better and recovering better and
looking better so i'm pretty excited
that this is going to be the next wave
of people just going wow i have more
energy and time than i did before wow
so are there a couple of top modalities
that you know of that are in the upgrade
lab that
people would be excited about
there's one of the ones that that's
unusual is called pulse electromagnetic
frequency therapy sounds cool
well this is a very powerful
electromagnet that turns on and off and
people say oh magnets on humans that's
such
pseudoscience this is so strong though
that you put it on your arm and and your
arms like to do like your muscles are
involuntarily because it makes sense i
sat on one of these okay is it
so it was on a bed it was on a bed and
then there was a top piece that goes on
top of you yes and i did this just the
other day at a clinic like a rehab kind
of clinic i did a little like infrared
and then i did that bed and you turn the
dial up and i had it like on my lower
legs the top panel and as i slid it it
was a decent amount i suppose out of a
hundred i think i was at somewhere
around 60 or so 65 and as i slid that
top panel to
sandwich my body between it and i pulled
it over my over my hips and over my
stomach i went oh god turn it down like
all of a sudden you're like that has a
feeling it's almost like a nerve pain in
a way in but you can really feel it but
it has like a electrical stem kind of
like reaction to the body but it has
like a dull achiness to it even and it
hits on a it hit on a spot like my
friend who did it she said it it's
interesting because it's not like you
feel one spot and it targets pain in one
spot where it's at
and i experience that in my hip like my
right hip hips are such a common place
for it and it it's straightening things
out it's exercising tissues it's
releasing toxins and
it's actually creating bone density so
people who do that a lot have bones that
are denser than karate masters and the
heaviest things
so who would have thought this could
make a difference you couldn't have done
this 15 years ago because we didn't have
the technology to do it it was just
emerging back then
and so there's all these things where we
look back and say the history of
exercise is
pick up rocks and run away from tigers
that's all there was right and that's
what you do at the gym like the rocks
are metal kits or maybe an elastic band
or something
we do stuff with ai where you can get
more
cardiovascular training in five and a
half minutes than a one hour spin class
and this is validated at university
studies that i didn't pay for
and
in the course of two months you can
spend a total of three and a half hours
on an exercise bike not per day or per
week but over three months so almost no
time at all
12 improvement in vo2 max which is more
than anyone can get by doing a spin
class five days a week
right and so all that time you get back
so you got the benefits
but you didn't have to invest time and
energy so then where do you put the time
and energy after that well you can come
and do neurofeedback you can train your
brain with the extra time so that that's
where it's going to get but the pulse
electromagnetic frequency thing if you
have a sore neck like nikki bellaps she
had a huge neck injury right she had a
huge neck injury so we took her to
upgrade labs and when she was doing her
recovery for the comeback fight i worked
with her on recovering got her on
collagen and she did one session of the
upgrade labs pulse the electromagnetic
frequency stuff and check up so oh my
god my neck isn't hurting like it really
made a difference for her
how often would you recommend that then
well she did one and it fixed it so
probably three times a week but i've had
countless people come into upgrade labs
they do one session go this pain i've
had for 10 years just went away and it
just stays gone because the body was
stuck there and you generate more
electricity with a magnetic frequency
and people going what you can't do this
at a gym like well no you can't because
that's not what gyms do but you can do
it at upgrade labs because it's actually
a human upgrade center is what we're
calling it because this isn't about
lifting rocks and chasing or running
away from tigers
we can do better and this is because of
ai and because of machine learning i
just want my time back and i want more
energy than i was born with and if i can
get those i win
yeah that is yeah that's a win yeah well
yeah maybe then when you were born with
baby sleep a lot but maybe since you
were like what 16 or 18.
that's a fair point yeah i i started
going off the rails even as a young teen
oh geez
wow fascinating i'm i'm so excited i i
hope you know
i hope that the lab comes to scottsdale
soon but in the meantime um good luck
that's that's i just love that um you
know technology is allowing us to
feel better look better
think better
no wonder why the world is growing in in
technology in such a fast way because
we're not only upgrading through the
technology but the technology is helping
our brains upgrade the technology even
more
it is and you you said something a bit
esoteric earlier about
you know where your spirit is is in the
body or not
you can use technology to uplift the
spirit and evolve more quickly than you
could have by sitting in a cave a
thousand years ago and it's okay to do
that and you can also use technology to
totally quash human development so
technology is a tool the question is
who's in charge of the technology and
what did you decide the goal was and as
long as you're using it in a good way
you can be calmer and faster
and happier than you were before and
that's what makes me happy
thanks dave thanks for helping us all
upgrade
uh you're welcome danica and thanks for
sharing your really good energy on your
show i i really like your podcast i like
your curiosity and i like your your
quickness thanks everybody for listening
to the pretty intense podcast today i
hope you enjoyed it if you like what you
heard today and you want to hear more
please click on the subscribe button